well our projects to go green affecting
our natural playgrounds
two years ago nevada voters said the
state must receive 50 percent of its
energy from renewable sources by the
year 2030.
and tonight a massive proposal is
getting heat over how it could affect
where we hike
bike and camp the i-team's david charge
takes us there
this is the site of a battle against
battleborn
if you listen closely you can hear the
war cries
you know we are screaming to the top of
our lungs
to try to save this mesa lisa childs is
talking about the mormon mesa
a sprawling flat topped hill 45 miles
northeast of the las vegas valley
she wants to save it from the proposed
battle-born solar project
a solar array that would cover the more
than 9 000
acres here with panels batteries and
roads
i don't want to look at 9180 acres of
solar panels when i come up here
childs took us up on the mesa showing us
why she and thousands of others have
vacationed
and moved here standing here i'm looking
at three states
vanette christensen is one of those
people too we've traveled here for years
even before we moved here
thousands come to this natural
playground to ride and relax
camp and create a big draw the double
negative
a piece of art entrenched in the ground
and to lose those things that really
benefit our community as a safe
playground
we are sad to try and see that happen
but access to all this could be lost if
the bureau of land management approves
the estimated billion dollar
investment that if completed would take
up nearly 150 allegiant stadiums
or two-thirds of manhattan island arivia
power
the company behind this says the solar
arrays
12 feet tall at their max would be set
back and not visible from below
the argument for big systems is that
they're cheap
dr robert bain is a distinguished
professor of mechanical engineering at
unlv
he says he doesn't know enough to make a
determination about the project
but says its location is important not
just to its opponents
but to its stakeholders the
decommissioned reed gardner power plants
trunk lines are here
a power artery just waiting to be tapped
i'm not against the renewable energy i'm
just against losing this beauty
baim says other options like putting
solar panels on carports or garages
though renewable are more expensive i
think when somebody wants to build
this big of a plant that
it's it's got some potential that should
be looked at for sure
looking at this is methodical blm
identifying potential conflicts with
battleborn
the project is not in one of the
agencies solar zones and right now
it's deemed a low priority but just as
stones throw away in these parts lies
the gemini solar project
also from arevia and approved for
building on public land
i don't believe public lands were ever
intended to be solar farms
or any type of industry they were meant
to be public lands
for the public to enjoy the battle over
battleborn is just beginning
studies will be completed and more input
gathered
as our energy needs grow and time ticks
toward nevada's energy goals
it's just going to totally
destroy this area i mean that's the best
way i can put it a spokesman for arevia
said battleborn's managing partner was
unable to be interviewed but they did
answer some of our questions
they tell the i-team they estimate the
project would create 2600 jobs and
provide the daytime energy needs of half
a million homes but as you heard
neighbors fear building it
would decimate the moapa valley's
recreation-based economy
as the benefits of green energy are
weighed against
building one i'm david charns 8 news now